welcome to this video's Magnus Carlsen
okay did I play this guy before I did ok
I'm going to play the Zi set up yeah I
don't know against this b6 business I
had problems against this I remember I
mean I don't know that that I don't mind
us so much but this early 95 bishop
asics constantly proved to be tricky ok
he has prevented Bishop g5 hmm is f for
a move or not I don't need to play it I
wonder if I should maybe I should just
improve a little bit of before i do that
now Bishop e3 93 those kind of moves
it's not clear that i have to play a
form immediately ok see what is he
intending really f5 f5 is possible
yeah okay I'm just going to develop f5
looks a bit weird without white having
played t5 but it's probably okay d 5 is
not a good idea and 93 is blundering
stuff yeah the thing is this is a bit a
bit unstable weather the rookies is
hanging in a way it's unprotected and
the night is also unprotected this is a
bit looks a bit off let's say but not
clear that I can really benefit from it
the idea is queen queen bee three maybe
on Queen d3e for this kind of ideas
Queen d3 was and move anyway
and I can play so that I Queen d7 for
example covering both pieces
hmm no
yeah but this are not i'm not sure about
i mean i understand the point but i get
i get f foreign and the center can prove
to be a can prove to be vulnerable
because of this is somewhat somewhat
problematic rook okay so Queen a for
loop t1 or what is what is good here c4
immediately is also a move that sense
that looks looks like the most direct
way threatening Nigeria threatens c6 and
c4 is check
and
kind of frustrating a just you just
played it instantly like well you're not
threatening anything buddy maybe check
yeah it seems to be okay for him I don't
know why but it seems to be okay
you can even play route Jeff hmm take
our form
yeah 93 rookie for is simply possible
Jeff but my night is hanging him nc5
Hanks unbelievable
Jerry I really don't know what the spoon
this position I really don't know
I really have no idea I mean I really
it's really not possible that i was was
worse after c4d takes 24 heads it's
really hard to believe but maybe this
maybe it's a case I mean I don't know I
cannot really believe it but maybe it is
maybe it's really the case okay
time morning 94 is a problem now for
night f2
I don't see a defense this is a problem
I really don't see any kind of defense
to that cannot play age three
and I have no move I have really have no
more nigeria on I devtools just winning
i have no move against that 3d strange I
mean so you went d4 yeah so so what is
wrong yeah I mean this is never ever
okay for black this is just this is just
a totally unstable position here I black
cannot be clearly better anything that's
simply not possible yeah not not with
night here and d4 and things like that
and it's all hanging by a thread this is
protecting from the side where I can
always go nyah g3 or g4 the night on 16
is unprotected the night of h7 is badly
placed so this this cannot be worse for
white but I meet probably maybe this is
really wrong I mean it's kind of
frustrating that you just takes it and
place all this quickly and it's good for
him but well it is really easy to play
because everything else just flat out
losers but it is so it is good for him
so I have to have to play differently
here it seems that Queen a voice right
hmm Kevin and then just um just slow
move relatively slow moves 97-94 now
this is why I couldn't really believe
this whole thing with e4 in solving of
course this is just just gives me pretty
pretty good pieces at five now is good
from 96 yeah probably this is the way to
improve I was thinking I really thought
that well Queen d3 well if it's works if
it works it works but other than that
it's it's fantastic of course yeah this
hangs the things and so on all his
pieces hanging at c4 c6 efore f5 it's
really rare for pieces are unprotected
nothing's falling he can just
counter-attack and here I'm really good
yeah amazing me it's really it's really
worse push if I have to seems to be a
little bit tougher but check it's
amazing how bad this really is i mean
computer once play Queen oh yeah why
didn't I do that Queenie 6 check quincy
form yeah my idea was this and I thought
I have counter play with my own see porn
but I okay this is good right at five I
didn't see the move oh thats not really
difficult rook takes Queen see a chick
yeah not very technically alert at the
moment him I'm okay but it was totally
unnecessary can go go here and is just
much much better maybe winning yeah
computer says I'm winning air he's
winning and he is giving me this chance
magic life after that i'm just using but
i didn't find anything an idea five with
one minute on the clock it's doable i am
even attacking the Queen now this is
really bad ah yeah I should have seen
that so I'm going to win the exchange in
this position but he's got tons of
counter play of course it's not like I'm
winning or anything it's not clear what
you should do computer wants to do this
funny funny sequence check
and calls it equal yeah difficult what
no no what what happened there a day I
must play it okay well not a good time
at the moment thanks for watching